okay so exciting Tauron Samuel leads
here and I am in Hall and Hall is a
beautiful place whether you like it or
not it's a pretty good investment area
and I'm just gonna be meeting one of my
students you may know him he's named
Alastair Cunningham and he's just taking
on a property in this area I'm not sure
what number it is I think we are close
outside this property the figures on
this are going to blow you away
so we'll reveal everything once inside
hey hey I'm good Knievel around what's
gonna happen
we're in Hall Alistair's going to show
us around is it nice it's it's in the
process of getting refunds that's
alright okay he's gonna show us around
and then you get a reveal of figures
yeah but but how much did you put down
for this property and just legal fees
seven hundred and fifty pounds is how
much you put down and you're gonna yeah
and you're gonna be getting nice prop
each month so he's put down seven
hundred fifty-pound he's gonna get back
about four hundred and fifty pounds
which means the return on investment is
like what a thousand percent yes
thousand percent return on investment
and he's going to ultimately own it it's
a lease option agreement which is
incredible yes show us around and then
we'll give you them one of the videos
okay okay so coming from this is going
to be so this is going to be a hatch
amount big enough for a communal area
yeah you can't see on the video but it
is it is not too bad okay so excuse the
mess
for Christmas I've just been a bit what
about that what prepared obviously
partition walls will be put in and this
is going to be bedroom one so you have
to put a partition wall in yeah turn
this into a for bed hey you know
upstairs there's three bedrooms yes
there is just two dollars in single so
this is gonna be a bedroom yeah I mean
is it weird having a bedroom downstairs
is that normal it's quite common mm-hmm
the new carpet throughout
now obviously you only put down 750
pounds yes but you have got a refurb
yeah so how much is the refurb gonna be
coming in three and a half years not bad
not bad
okay the sofas come with the house you
keep it the house that are free so we
could potentially get them clean and
whole well that's all we have home how
close are we to the center about five
minutes so with five minutes from the
centre and the EU I've just invested how
much 27 million yeah 27 million year old
but it's still a poo hole I'm only
kidding cause a nice place okay and into
the kitchen because Paul supporter
oversaturated online yes some parts are
yeah and it's got a nice gym with a HM
oh you mean half a metre of workspace
per tenant so there's gonna be four
tents
I mean we've got plenty
nice kitchen yeah that's where the
naughty people can eat their breakfast
yeah so this wall had an issue and it's
all been repaired I've done is dump a
massive issue always down something easy
to fix
no is he right people it's easy it
obviously depends on the severity of the
damage but damn sometimes people think
oh my gosh let's cut down therefore it's
an absolute deal breaker but you've
three the high castle grounds and that's
included that guy so the damn look at
that guy's much this wasn't rising bad
this was down to a week above yeah so
that's been sorted out either when you
had lease option agreement you need to
get a survey don't you yeah well I did
yes because you need to know you just
because it's a free house it's a good
house right so just be the three
thousand music we now this is the
kitchen so have a downstairs toilet so
it's WC just a single bathroom so all
the other bedrooms ensuite does it
matter they're not honest or not so for
bedroom because we've got this toilet I
mean why not says bathroom so there's
got you've got two toilets per for
people people so it's on the sorry a
toilet / - people yes so it's not too
bad right in some areas particularly
some of the northern places like all the
fact you've got two toilets with four
people you can definitely rent out here
what you thinking about 3 to 5 3 to 3
yeah this room itself all right here
5350
so you think this room will burn out for
350 and you don't have to pay the bills
yes yeah and this partition how much did
it cost to turn this big through lounge
into two beds two hundred-pound that's
not all the money so you could just take
a a 3-bit house and to turn it into a
4-bit multi left with a partition and
the father's dirty Linda parent yes yeah
you already have them
I mentioned that cost that was in whole
you can get things done cheap so to
convert I single that into a multi-layer
the single net you come to get what like
five hundred first yeah 500 500 so you
don't get 450 pounds to farm in Japan's
there's a single that but where
everything is a multi let take us
upstairs
yes yeah
this is like the behind the scenes of
winners on a Wednesday winners on the
Wednesday we sit down and we interview
our success students now we check up on
that see after this video there's not
much he's doing in here
no bathrooms okay yeah I mean to the
single room this is the smallest room in
the house these rooms are just as a
motive that what's the minimum square
footage of the smallest room seventy
square feet 7 square feet we're gonna do
the ultimate check-up to see if this is
seventies where think I'm I usually say
if you fix a bed in it and the chest
patrols in the wardrobe and you still
got some floor space yeah but if we want
to be extra sure then you need to just
do the measure which isn't like this
because Mike like my feet are exactly
one foot which is really convenient so 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 it's just over 10 and
this way one
three four five six seven and a half
so seven times ten seventy square foot
just over so this is it's actually super
thick this would be the cheapest room
and get about 300 per month for this and
would be a single bed set drawers or
brand-new furniture and the whole time
to be painted but again it looks pretty
nice I have all my heat channels with an
ingrate and so we have more green walls
white white foods so also go fire alarm
systems doc watch it why did you choose
gray just close no not be okay just
I think Gray's I just don't like beige
or white so and Lisa chooses the one
that I hate more that we ate too much
we've got both of them grievers quite
good quite good work shows through the
two rows yeah these fibers this change
is just oh yeah how do you know if it's
a final because if it's like that is not
a five-dollar hide or even more solid
yeah if you if you punched it it would
not break you just saw some lights on
Saul right little step up the processes
again of the fire ball has been
installed and you're gonna put new
furniture because that bad personally I
would rather sleep on the floor but it's
nice so you'll get what about 350 for
this awesome
nice Oh what was that
what do you think that is oh my it's not
it's not that is let shows the front
this is two full moon arm that is very
interesting how interesting
I wonder what this happen to go upstairs
I don't notice you've not seen that
letter before obvious you have never
there's a stamp on it okay open it up I
know what this is
hey please fit this is fun whoever this
is from deserves a high five gone good
on ya please forgive my direct approach
but would you be entry is not from one
of my students no let me see the front
Commissioner message Rob new deck oh I
don't know him but he's probably been to
one of my crash courses let me see what
he said please forgive my director
pressure would you reduce peak you're
probably my face upon an eye I probably
less does not actively properties that
match your requirements we specialize in
helping homeowners you make currently
apologizing negative net would say
you've been beaten to it buddy
alastair coating on was faster I don't
keep looking at it let me keep looking
at it oh that was faster because he's
one of my students if you might be able
to know if not please discard this
letter yeah we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna frame it just to remind us
that we caught on if you are looking if
you're a tenant leaving the property
businesses on to landlord well you know
what at least he's trying
yeah like the guy and I love the fact I
teach my students to do this that he's
put it in a in a colorful letter and
handwritten it like that that that is
the perfect envelope the message inside
wasn't great I don't like that please
forgive my dog right response murder my
letters the better
alastair how did you get where you can
get there in a minute just keep showing
up okay that's so cool funny isn't it
we should ring him and we should we
should get him to come to the crash
course and okay here's the mean because
the others are named this one oh this
one's really nice this is the big room
Disney's decorating I just couldn't take
it again the carpets to stay there to be
cleaned
you should be so proud of this house I'm
a I'm stoked
that's not to love it I mean it's a
little bit in the sense of it just meets
their career that's cool mmm coming out
we could leave them yeah anyway let's
just cut to the chase I want you to talk
me through the figures a little bit okay
you sent her letter just like that one
yes like that one it was better it was
better and you and you did that walls at
the crash course okay okay so while you
were either training with me you wrote a
letter and you sent it out and you sent
to this address and then they contacted
you and that what happened to this one's
been a little bit slow and happening and
because the vendor was very I'll try to
help them out and you know exhaustion
Lawson's exhausting the options I was
trying to help them and it did go
through trying to rain out of a game
that didn't work and so they had no
equity so what was the outstanding
mortgage about 90,000 pounds is the
outstanding mortgage what's the value
eighty five so it's only worth eighty
five it's dropped in price the mortgage
they probably got a 100 percent move
it's really now they can't sell it
because they if they if they sell it for
85 they're going to be sure yeah so that
they have to wait for the property to go
up in value but while they're waiting
for the government value it's getting
worse and worse we can they can't rent
it out because they haven't got the four
thousand pounds or whatever is you
probably go to cheap yeah no I mean you
know the right people so they haven't
got the move so they were stuck in
motivated seller so what did you offer
them and well I'd offered them for my
mom okay so I might in for de predamond
and in five years time I can buy it for
eighty-eight thousand pounds because the
for-loop on a month apena was slightly
over the mortgage but they actually came
and they pin that off the mortgage so
they've got like a guaranteed when it's
a 400 pound which is less than the going
rate yeah you're gonna pay for all the
repairs and you know that but then
you've got a guaranteed sale yeah in
five years for eighty eight thousand now
if five years time chances are this
house is probably worth a lot more than
idea who knows but you have the option
not the obligation yeah so it's like the
easiest way to buy properties with no
money down or very little down I was
saying I did deals like this people that
solution option agreement on the show I
did deals like this seven eight nine
years ago I'm now cashing in big and I'm
now getting messages from from because
people are selling their problems to me
now some of them have gone up like my 50
grand 60 grand
seventy grams you've seen the email and
the members are like oh it's gone up a
lot I'm like yeah because that was the
agreement we had if you do one of these
nails Alastair said that he paid 750
pounds for the solicitors make sure so
my arm is getting tired make sure that
you have a solicitor legally represent
the seller because otherwise when you
come to buy in five seven years it's
gonna have got massive lien value
they'll be like I don't want to set with
you anymore or they want to renegotiate
the price so make sure you do probably
make sure you get a solicitor involved
at least obviously really fantastic way
to go super proud of online is there
Wi-Fi this isn't the first one you've
done
this is this before like this and you've
also got you've got the reprimand to
deal sauce Ingham packaging all kinds of
stuff what advice would you give to
someone that was watching this my advice
genuinely would be all starts at the
crash course get yourself along to the
crisis disaster my journey started yeah
and you know war it's liquid it's been
about a year since I went to the crash
so in other words stop what you're doing
there's a link below it's a free
invitation to come and spend two days
with me at the property investors crash
course come and spend a couple of days
we've made the crash course learn how to
do this dip yourself it'll blow your way
and transform your mind for and alright
peace out guys scenic time
[Music]